many people are claiming there's a
bubble going on today and there's a lot
of people that are getting upset when
say
marcus is not going to crash this
thing's going to go up this is the
greatest economy we've ever had
you got to keep investing into the
market so who is right so today
i'm going to be a lawyer i'm not a
lawyer but i'm going to be a lawyer and
i'm going to give you 10 points
on why i am leaning towards a bubble and
a crash
and you will have to make that decision
for yourself and pick apart my argument
below comment say i totally disagree
you have no clue what you're talking
about but i'm going to make my case
we'll do some math i'll give you some
trends
some of it will be technical some of it
will be simple but by the end you'll be
able to make a decision for yourself
whether i'm
making a good case or not so let's get
right into it so there's this guy named
uh warren buffett who's a very wealthy
man very successful man who
took his berkshire hath away from where
it was to where it's at today he's worth
around 80 200 billion dollars
and when he gives advice about money
people listen he has a famous saying
that he's been saying for a long time
you've heard this before you've read
this before
be fearful when people are greedy be
greedy when people are
fearful are people scared today are
people greedy today what do you think
you answered that one right there for
yourself so
if you got to be fearful when people are
greedy and today everyone's being greedy
thinking they're gonna oh gamestop
arriving on
you know american airlines bitcoin
people are so greedy today maybe we
ought to pay attention to what he said
matter of fact check this out
there's a guy named michael jordan okay
who has a rookie card
this is his best rookie card 1986 flier
and psa is the top grading company in
the world
there's only about 300 of these graded
at 10 okay
let me first give you the history of
what happened with this thing here
just march 22nd which is 11 months ago
this card sold for 48
000. then it went up to 51 600
this is when the last dance came out it
came out a little before that
then it went to 96 then it went to 150.
just a month and a half ago two months
ago this card was selling for 151
000 in the marketplace you know what it
just sold for
738 000
for one card in 11 months this card went
from 48
000 to 738 now is it a 48 000 car
absolutely not is it a 738 000 car
today when there's 300 of these out
there i don't know about that so why are
people spending this kind of money
is it because they're greedy is it
because they made a lot of money is it
because everyone's making money on the
stock market and they have extra money
to spend
i can't answer that but i'll let you
answer that one here now let's get a
little bit more technical here
so many times when you want to price
a company's p e ratio price to earnings
you take the formula and you divide
whatever the stocks price is
by their earnings you divide that and
you come up with the p e ratio right so
p e ratio
typically historically you know
companies are between 15 to 17 percent
domestic is about 17.47
today on p e ratio let me give you a
couple examples
of companies where their pe ratios right
now you ready
so tesla right now p e ratio is 1243
meaning it is overpriced meaning people
are banking on what this could go in the
future
but it's not worth 763 billion dollars
today which is why
so many people are shorting the tesla
stock now you may say pat give me a
break it's elon musk
you talk a lot of good things about elon
musk elon musk is a genius no question
about it as long as he runs tesla
this thing's going to go to a price like
that however let's take a look at some
other companies what their p
ratios are so tesla was what if you want
to get a little closer
1243 right let's look at microsoft
big company bill gates pe ratio 36.39
you can just stay right here if we go to
facebook what's facebook
facebook p ratio 26.71 that's a big
company ran by zuck he's still running
it
let's go to another company like apple
what is apple's p e ratio
36.27 let's go to another one uh i don't
know
uh give me another one kai let's do
amazon okay
amazon's p e ratio is 77.90
high right let me take you back to tesla
you mean to tell me 1256
tesla you mean to tell me tesla's a 771
billion auto company based on today not
future earnings
i don't know about that this is
concerning so now
if the average historically p e ratio
for a company
has been 17.47 take a look at this
today it is 39.86
look at the history of pe ratios for s p
500.
look at the history of it 12 13 26
okay you know 23 okay
let's go to o1 911 happens
42 what happens after 9 11
it drops right okay let's go over here p
e ratios look how high it is mortgage
boom you remember that the bust
the bubble boom 39.86 these are three
trends that we can look at now
let's go take a look at schiller and by
the way for the
max and amin you need to know that the
lowest p e ratio we've ever had was 5.31
which is 1917. the highest we ever had
was 09 that's the big market crash 123.
right now let's go to schiller
p e ratio with schiller the difference
between schiller's robert schiller came
out with the p e ratio and they called
it the schiller p e ratio
what he did is typically when the ucp
ratio of tesla being
you know the number i showed you which
is what the uh uh uh what was it
1200 the 12 month p e ratio trailing 12
month of tesla is what
161.61 12 month which is still high
not 1200 but still high what schiller
did is
he went 10 years is what he did so all
he did is he took that pe ratio that's
the day or maybe 12 months he said let's
go 10 years
and see what numbers it gives us and
look we found that here take a look at
this
today the schiller p e ratio is 35.65
second highest ever when it was 30 it
was black tuesday what happened to black
tuesday look at this
how the market dropped do you see it
what happened
in 9 11 boom market drop look where the
p e ratio was shiller p ratio 10 years
we're at 35.65 that is not a good trend
to be looking at so so far we've covered
a few different things we've covered p e
ratio
tesla i give you a few other companies
we've covered shiller a p
ratio we've covered when people are
fearful greedy greedy fearful
buffett we've covered the jordan card
that i showed you out of nowhere a forty
eight thousand dollars oh buy for seven
hundred thirty eight thousand dollars
how do you have that kind of money
now let's go to the next one the next
one is interest rates let's look at
interest rates okay
so when you look at interest rates
here's what you see
the history of interest rates in america
okay this kind of worldwide kind of
gives you an idea
you don't see anything being above what
it is today today is as low as it's ever
been now if we really kind of break it
down so you can
see it even deeper this is what you will
notice this
is the federal funds rate
62-year historical chart okay
rates were just a little over you know a
decade ago they were what
5.21 okay six point five five so
2001 market tanks we take it down to
0.98 under a bush administration
to help the economy come back up but we
raise the interest rates again right
obama comes into office takes office he
keeps it low below
one percent for nearly his entire term
and then trump comes and says we can't
keep it at this the rates go a little
bit higher but then eventually covet hit
we have to take the rates low to what
point
zero nine we haven't been this slow for
a long time go to the history of america
what it looks like okay
here what we have what happened in 81
this is carter
if you look at carter when he came in
rates went to the roof cds were paying
15 16
at one point what happened with carter
one term president reagan came up came
up with reagan
reaganomics and he brought it lower so
when you look at this
and you say interest rates who cares
about low interest rates pat
well let me show you 30 year fix and
i'll kind of give you an idea why this
is so important to look at if you go
right now
and we type in your zip code this is
boca raton
uh interest rates today for 30 year
fixed is roughly what
2.875 at this bank chase is 2.92
let's just say three hundred three or
three percent is the interest rate today
for what
for 30-year mortgage rate today's what
three percent
so then let's just go do math what does
this have to do with anything pat i
don't know where you're going with this
can you kind of help us out better on
some what you're doing
yeah let's just say you're buying a 500
000 house today i'm gonna do the math
for you
say you're buying a 500 000 house today
and
you are gonna go with the current rate
which is what three percent over 30
years
your payment today would be what stay
over here your payment would be what
2108 why is that such an important
number
let me show you something simple on the
paper here and hopefully this will make
sense
here's how rates work when interest
rates are
low price of homes are what high
but when interest rates are high price
of homes are what
low meaning right now if the rates are
three
i'm gonna be able to buy five hundred
thousand dollar house because i'm
solving for
this i'm not solving for this i'm not
solving for this when people buy a house
they say what
i can't afford two thousand dollars a
month nobody says i can afford a half a
million dollar house you go to your
banker at chase that baby say
i think i can pay two thousand dollars a
month for a mortgage let me do the math
you qualify for three percent interest
rate we can go as high as 500 000
great i get that pre-approval letter
then i go to my realtor and i say
we can look at houses all the way up to
what 500 000
now here's a problem watch this here
if i raise this interest rate to six
percent which is what it normally was
is three thousand dollars same value
house but the rate went up to six
percent
if that interest rate goes to nine
percent what happens
mortgage goes to four thousand dollars
the couple's sitting at the bank saying
i can't pay
four thousand dollars a month but it's
still only five hundred thousand dollar
house so come over here i've done some
math for you to
simplify to take a look at this so if i
get a five hundred thousand dollar house
at three percent thirty years i'm paying
2108 a month
total i'm going to pay over 30 years at
758. if that goes to 6
i'm paying 29.98 1.79
if it's 9 4 000 1 million 448
this is the problem the problem is the
following
if i am solving for what if i'm coming
in and i'm solving for
the payment of 2108 and i tell my
mortgage guy
hey i can only do 2001 2100 payment per
month
and the rates today are six percent
guess what i can only get
i can only get a 351
000 house to be at that payment did that
make sense
which means today i may be able to
afford a five hundred thousand dollar
house because rates are three
but if the rates go to six percent i can
only afford a three hundred fifty one
thousand dollar house
and if the rates go to nine percent i
can only afford what
262 thousand dollar
house which means today real estate is
inflated
and uh if they keep the interest rates
this low pal keeps saying it's going to
stay for another three years
interest rates low price is high
interest rate goes high
prices go down so this is this is one
other thing to be thinking
about where people are buying houses
left and right odds and it's just
interest rates are so low
if it goes the other way around do not
be surprised if these same five hundred
thousand dollar houses are selling for
four
four hundred thousand three fifty and
same million dollar homes are selling
for
seven hundred thousand dollars six
hundred thousand dollars if that were to
happen so now let's go back to this
so is that a sign of a market crash yes
because we have kept the rates low for a
long time and we can't go low for too
long sometimes you would do it to just
boost the economy a little bit but to
keep
it for this long since obama came in
we kept the rates low below one percent
since 08 for this long this is like a
bodybuilder being on steroids growth
hormone
everything you put for 20 years you know
what happens to you eventually
you have a heart attack the market's
about to have a heart attack if we
continue like this
this is not something that's sustainable
over and over and over and over and over
again
that's another argument i'm making to
you now let's go to a complete different
argument
we just decide to raise the minimum wage
to what 15 bucks an hour it's about to
become official because biden's got the
senate house and obviously he's the
president and you know kamala can vote
so it goes to 15 an hour cbo does a case
saying hey if we go to 15 bucks an hour
you
i just want you know we're going to lose
1.4 million
job 1.4 million americans are going to
lose their job no
we have to go to 15 an hour you can't
make a case today it's going to 15 bucks
an hour
no problem um which industry
has the most minimum wage employees
which industry wall street
that funds most of these political
campaigns now
uh real estate no which industry
has the most employees making minimum
wage well let's take a look
well according to u.s facts here if you
go and look at it
food preparation and serving related
has the most minimum wage employees
last 12 months lots of jobs were lost
no around 15 million jobs were lost in
hospitality hotel restaurants
so the industries that took the biggest
hit those small restaurants that took
the biggest said now we're going to
raise the minimum wage for the waiter
waitresses that work there
and the bus boys we're going to now take
them so i'm running a restaurant i'm
already running on small margins of 3 4
now you're adding that on top of it if
restaurant business industries go out of
business who gets affected what do you
buy at restaurants you just buy burgers
no you buy beer
alcohol liqueur liquor paper man other
industries could be effective yeah you
know i spoke to andrew zimmerman
who has his own show and he's been
around tv for a long time expert when it
comes down to
a restaurant and he goes deals with the
white house when it comes down to
restaurants he says nearly 50 million
people are affected by
this entire decision that was made with
the restaurant business
you know with the coveted shutdown
they're being affected tremendously
does that potentially lead to a bubble
and an effect maybe because it's delayed
pain that's about to come up to small
business owners and what are we going to
do every single time send one point 1.9
1.9 trillion dollars to people is that
really effective
well now that we're talking about the
1.9 trillion dollars why don't we take a
look at the
1.9 trillion dollars and how much money
we've printed
in the history of america i don't know
let's just take a look you ready
here's what it looks like on what we've
done history of america when we print
money
2 000. look we're at 2 000. nothing
crazy okay
and then all of a sudden what do you see
goes up goes up goes up and what do we
do in 2020 with covet
look at this from oh wait how much we
printed with quantitative easing
but then look at that spike we go up
that's a scary site some
say 40 percent of all the money
in the history of america was printed
just in 2020
some say it's 18 but it's between 20 to
40 percent
almost a fifth of all u.s dollars were
created
this year fifth which means what 20
percent
so do we keep solving problems by
printing money we got a printing press
let's just keep printing money it's okay
we'll solve the problem that way
that's the way to go about solving the
problem right that's what we should do
no that leads to fake success
and fake money and what is fake success
and fake money do you ever met a fake
rich person
what happens to them eventually they
lose the cards they lose the house they
lose everything because they were fake
rich they were never rich they were rich
on the outside but they were never rich
on the inside you ever see these people
that's very happy
oh my gosh it's so wonderful i'm so
blessed as if they have zero problems
deep down and said they have a lot of
issues there's a lot of fake
millionaires today a lot of fake success
today a lot of that going on today
and by the way we can't blame many of
them because we are promoting this
this is the greatest time to get rich
take advantage of it
be greedy this is what you should do and
folks don't realize we're not talking
about sets of money
aside we're not talking about emergency
fund we're not talking about get ready
that if something bad happens
we're not talking about the rainy day
all we're talking about is flamboyant
this person did this that person did
this
all this stuff comes together so now let
me go to another one
excessive valuations i already gave you
when we talked about tesla
but some of the excessive valuations
with robin hood gamestop american
airlines
you know bed bath and beyond what is
that all about that is another sign
where the market today can be
manipulated because if one person sends
a tweet this person goes on gamestop
reddit
strange things are going on when
companies are being overvalued and
they're not worth that even
the doge coin ceo says we're not a 10
billion dollar company i don't even know
what the hell is going on here
we're not a 10 billion dollar company
the ceo
makes a comment like that where the own
ceo is concerned about that
even musk said i think we're overpriced
today in a tweet
but people are saying no we're not keep
buying keep buying
keep buying that's another concern and
then last but not least
economic expansion went for how long i
think economic expansion went for 128
months no one's even talking about it
today but economic expansion went for
about 128 months okay when you go for
128 months of economic expansion then
comes kobe we forgot about it that the
market grew for 128 months
nearly 11 years and then because of
covet we had to shut down a market tank
in one month if you remember that and
then what happened but take hold it out
take covet never happened say covet
never happened there is no coronavirus
nothing happened and 2020 goes the way
it did
how does the market go where does it go
35 040 000
that's still a bubble that's been going
for 11 years
no econ economy expansion goes for 11
years and the debt of the country keeps
rising the way it's rising for us
and the interest rates that's not
sustainable eventually
there is a crash that's going to come
and it's
not going to be pretty and this wasn't a
crash in 2020
we did not have a market crash but 2020
was such a bad year to rough
no no no people got unemployment
benefits people got stimulus checks
centered and people got billed
people got bailed out in so many
different ways where people didn't even
want to get a job because they were
making more money staying home than
getting a job
this is not a sign of a market that's
growing okay
this is a 11 year bubble that's been
brewing that's been going up and when it
drops
it is not going to be pretty so having
said that that's my argument
i made about 10 or 11 points to you you
agree
put thumbs up you disagree put thumbs
down but give me your argument below
and if you want to find out more you say
pat this is scary what if this actually
does happen how can i prepare myself
i got a video i also did titled eight
ways to prepare for market crash if
you've never watched it
click here to go watch it thank you
everybody bye
you